so there was a fairly innocuous question
yesterday on the nfl on fox instagram
page which is tougher making a catch
while guarded by stefan gilmore or
breaking up a pass while guarding
michael thomas devonte parker who has
done the former not the latter chimed in
with option a making a catch while being
guarded by stephon gilmore
that's when it got a little interesting
because that's when michael thomas
decided to defend his honor and to
attack
mercilessly
devante parker uh and uh parker parker
went back at him parker parker said uh
let me get targeted 300 times a game
which is a reference to the number of
balls that end up coming michael
thomas's way of course they come his way
because he catches them the dagger
though came from thomas who ultimately
said it took you six years and 17 weeks
to have a good game
gtfoh blame your parents not no
quarterback boom
roasted michael thomas gets the victory
there but but uh thankfully because they
had that little exchange chris we uh we
have an idea for a draft the toughest
one-on-one feats right now in football
uh the first pick had better be covering
michael thomas or we're gonna hear it on
social media from the great saints
receiver you've got the trivia question
for me lay it on me
i don't want to mess with michael thomas
i mean i'm dead serious he's one of
those guys you got to think twice about
if you want to say something negative
because if you see him i feel like he'd
probably step up and be like all right
let's fight and then i don't want to
fight him i don't so uh he is scary that
way uh that was already left him out of
your top five receivers you're already
on his list
he's in the top five he's not the best
receiver in football though i don't care
if he counts
here he comes here sorry the truth
sometimes all right here we go last
season stefan gilmour became the sixth
cornerback to win
nfl defensive player of the year
what hall of famer was the first
cornerback to win that award
oh wow
uh
my canes
oh
so close but yet so far
no that would be mel
from the pittsburgh steelers
1975. that was a new one i did not know
that
uh but yeah i didn't know that either
how do you stand out but how do you
stand out on that defense that tells you
how good mel blunt was with all those
guys they had in 1975 a super bowl
championship season and just that
laundry list of great defensive players
to just be the best defensive player on
your team
is is worthy of of a giant trophy uh so
all right well good well now i know
something that i didn't know okay you
get the first pick who do you have in
this draft of the toughest one-on-one
feats right now in football
well i mean there's a lot of good ones
here i don't know how long your list is
but i got quite a few i i think the
first one that you know gosh there's
like i have like three in the running
for my number one but i think the
toughest one on one feet in football
right now would be to block aaron donald
one on one as a guard that's where i'm
gonna go with it i mean aaron donald
again he's just one of those guys that
is starting to become whenever i get on
a podcast or interview a player or do
anything like that i ask them about a
defensive player and i before you can
ask them the question aaron donald comes
out of their mouth that's how special
people think he is and what a game
record he is let alone he can move in
short areas like a really awesome third
down running back except he's 285 pounds
and you know can bench press 500 pounds
and squat who knows what else i mean
he's just an absolute muscled up freak
who's twitchy explosive and almost
unblockable i mean it's it's really to
that point i mean there's there's really
only one or two guards in football that
you can say hey
you know the majority of the game we
think that we're going to give you a
fighting chance against aaron dotto most
teams just try to double team him and
send the line that way slide the line
out of the way so he doesn't just abuse
people
yeah no i agree with you there and that
was under consideration for my first
pick but hey we talked about michael
thomas and trying to cover him
tyree kill is the guy that you do not
want to try to cover you're
disrespecting michael thomas oh my gosh
you're such a jerk what a jerk you are
mike
i'm sorry but but it's true right i know
and it's not just the straight-line
speed it's the stopping it's the
starting it's the change of directions i
mean as a defensive back you're almost
like a bull rider right you're trying to
stay on the bull and the bull is the guy
you're covering you're trying to stay
close to him he knows where he's going
you have no idea and when the guy has
the speed the burst the stop the start i
think the stop is as impressive as the
acceleration when you can be going i
mean because there are a lot of people
out there who are fast and they need
about 40 yards to slow down after
running 40 yards as fast as they can
tyree kill can run 40 yards and by yard
43 he's standing still i mean that i
think is an overlooked skill so then you
stop you start again you go here you go
there and when you have that that
ability and that speed and that
acceleration and everything that goes in
it and the jumping ability on top of it
uh good luck nobody can nobody can cover
that one-on-one chris
no no nobody can i mean jalen ramsey's
the only guy that i saw that had legit
success against them without like help
but you're right because most corners
you know mike when you cover tyree kill
the first thing you have to do is take a
step back and you have to go oh my gosh
he's going to run by me i can't run with
him and then of course that opens up all
the other routes that you talked about
and his ability to stop on a dime and
restart makes that tougher too but yeah
like jalen ramsey is one of the only
guys i've seen that's challenged him at
the line of scrimmage and wasn't totally
fearful of his speed but i'm with you
that was uh in the running for my first
pick mike here's my next one i think
it's um tackling lamar jackson in the
open field you know i mean to me right
now that's that's got to be up there
with with all the great feats in
football or you know toughest things to
do i mean how many times do we see him
break ankles of a safety a linebacker a
corner no matter who it is i don't care
quarterback receiver wide receiver lamar
jackson's in the running for some of the
quickest feet in football especially
with the ball in his hands and you know
has some of that start restart ability
that you just talked about with tyree
kill but you know i mean it's like he's
like a dancer he's like a tote you know
uh attack what a tap dancer with the way
he moves and shuffles around and makes
people miss
yeah you know what i agree with you and
uh it's the combination of the speed the
agility and he'll run over you too
there's a little power
that he'll bring if you get in his way
he prefers not to take those hits but he
will deliver those hits if he has to in
that same vein and i could sandbag this
one maybe i'll sandbag this one now i'm
going to go ahead and use it
um you say tackling lamar jackson in the
open field yeah
go ahead i say i say
tackling patrick mahomes behind the line
of scrimmage one-on-one buying spying
pass
well trying to sack patrick mahomes
period i mean we it's it's the it's
rocky two when mickey has him chasing
the chicken around before he gets in
shape he eventually gets in shape and he
can figure it out but you cannot catch
patrick mahomes you cannot corral
patrick mahomes that was one of the big
talking points going into the super bowl
that front four of the san francisco
49ers right oh nick bose is going to go
get him no he's not because i don't care
about straight line speed i don't care
about measurables i don't care about
three cone draw i don't care about any
of that i care about putting the
football in the guy's hands you put the
football in his hands and you can't
catch patrick mahomes when he's trying
to buy time to throw the football so uh
once it's time to take off down the
field give me lamar jackson behind the
line of scrimmage nobody's getting their
hands on patrick mahomes hey i'm with
you i mean hey we have von miller at the
super bowl tell us what it's like to try
to tackle patrick mahomes right i mean
it's unlike anything you've seen you
know when you're right it's not all
about just straight speed it's mahomes
ability to pump the ball he's got great
body language to lean a guy one way and
make a miss you know i had written that
down too that was gonna be one of my
next picture you know i i phrased it as
spying patrick mahomes i mean we saw in
the afc championship game he ran down
the sidelines that was the spy he gave
the old shoulder head okie doke to and
made a miss and then ran down the
silence for a touchdown so i'm with you
you know the fact that he breaks all the
rules of what a quarterback does it
drops nine at 10 yards deep and invites
a guy up the field and then makes a miss
and then you know throws some laser beam
no look 30 yards down the field that's
insane it's insanity it really is it's
it's unbelievable all right i'm gonna
cha i mean i got you know hey we give
skill guys all the love all the time
we've hit some quarterbacks we've hit
some receivers i got to give some of the
big uglies some some credit here and to
me
one that you can't pay me enough for
okay you're going to have to whip out
some cash is if you ask
you know it if you have to take i know
where you're going
oh baby that's just a headache waiting
to happen i mean i'm just telling you if
i saw quentin nelson coming at me i'm
yelling to the ref like blow the whistle
blow the whistle please please or i'm
just diving at his shoelaces i'm going i
don't want any part of you don't touch
me you're going to destroy me to me that
is i mean we've seen it i mean come on
this is and you're around nfl players
mike i mean these are the men of men and
he's out there a few times a year we
show highlights of him just crushing
studs on the defensive side of the ball
upending them head hitting the ground
first head over feet doing whatever it
may be that to me would be one of the
toughest one-on-one feats in all of
football taking on that big sucker
yeah i agree with you you know what uh
yeah uh i was maybe i should have taken
that one round too but i still stand by
my patreon homes pick all right i have
plenty that i can choose from here i
hate to leave anyone out michael thomas
but i'm gonna go with tackling derek
henry
right
we we have seen no one want to get in
his way you don't want to do that
one-on-one your best chance is to go low
and hope he trips over your carcass
right
when when he gets when he gets a head of
steam
he is a freight train those first two
steps are your best chance because he's
yet to get to maximum capacity once he
gets going you are done uh i uh we told
him at the super bowl he's today's jim
brown and he really is what other
running back in today's nfl would even
begin to compare to jim brown and i hate
to use that term and i don't use it
lightly but that's what derek henry is
right now and i do not want to get in
his way and i don't think there are many
nfl players that relish the opportunity
to try to bring him down one on one no
no you're right i mean you could see it
you if you watch games you'll you'll see
people starting to turn down hits late
in the game or certainly not giving the
same intensity as early in the game
and you know it's just it's it's amazing
in a sport full of men yeah there's
certain times where derek henry looks
like a grown man playing with boys
running down the field so it is
impressive and you know even to go low
mike like it's scary because you know
one of those big knees comes up and hits
you in the side of the head it's night
night you're going to see birds flying
around and you're going to be like which
way did he go which way did he go so uh
that was one that made my list certainly
there's some good ones in here i had a
jump ball to deandre hopkins as a
possibility like covering him one-on-one
covering christian mccaffrey out of the
backfield you know in that situation oh
good luck good night if you're sitting
there on your heels and he's running at
you and you can cut any which way like
sorry that's not happening so those are
some other ones that uh were on my list
yeah blocking nick boson there as well
we talked about him as related to
patrick mahomes and and it just as
dominant are almost as dominant as in
aaron donald uh trying to keep that guy
out of the backfield and keep him off of
your quarterback and you know you
mentioned derrick henry and the business
decisions we've seen that's our last
memory of darrell rivas in the nfl the
business decision he made with that
still a sliver of hope for the kansas
city chiefs in that playoff game uh
darrell rivas wasn't having anything to
do with trying to tackle derrick henry
all right we're going to take a break we
all assume philip rivers is a one-year
rental for the indianapolis colts his
head coach apparently didn't get that
memo we'll discuss that next here on
profile
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports